The Battle of Wakanda in ​Avengers: Infinity
War was an event that will reverberate throughout
the MCU for years, and in one of its climactic
moments, two of the Avengers'​ biggest guns
failed to come through.
Fans have wondered ever since: how did Thanos
defeat Vision and Scarlet Witch so easily?
"I thought you were formidable, machine.
But you're dying, like any man."
The question was answered by Avengers: Infinity
War and Avengers: Endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo during a Twitter Q&A they conducted
for Wired's Tech Support series.
Essentially, they, along with screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely, knew
that the pair would have to be hobbled if
Thanos were to achieve his victory.
Vision's injury early on in the film was the
circumstance which allowed the Mad Titan to
narrowly avoid a whipping at the hands of
the two heroes.
Joe Russo explained:
"Vision gets skewered right at the very beginning
of that fight, so he's really not functioning
at full power."
He went on to say that Vision even becomes,
quote, "a liability in the fight," putting
Scarlet Witch at a disadvantage since she
has to protect him.
Anthony Russo chimed in to add this comment
about Corvus Glaive's sword:
"And as Vision mentions, that weapon had an
effect on him that he didn't expect."
Joe added that with Wanda and Vision cornered,
it takes the combined might of Captain America,
Falcon and Black Widow to get them out of
the jam.
Apparently, that early battle weakened Vision
enough that Wanda was forced to destroy the
Mind Stone mounted in Vision's forehead to
stop Thanos.
Of course, that only stopped Thanos for a
moment, since the Mad Titan used the Time
Stone to undo her action, and ripped the Mind
Stone from Vision's head himself, killing
him yet again.
With the final piece of the Infinity Gauntlet
in place, Thanos unleashed the snap heard
'round the universe, reducing Wanda and a
slew of other heroes to dust.
The Russo brothers previously clarified shortly
after Infinity War's release that, since they
knew that the Mind Stone-powered Vision would
be a primary target of Thanos and his Black
Order, it was necessary to render him vulnerable.
It just so happened that Glaive's attack on
Vision might have been the deciding factor
in the Mad Titan's ultimate victory.
Fortunately, as we all know, Thanos' victory
was eventually reversed during the events
of Endgame by a Stark Gauntlet-wielding Bruce
Banner after the Avengers' successful mission
through time.
Scarlet Witch, along with all of the other
dusted heroes, was revived, but Vision was
not, since he didn't die from the first snap.
This raises the question of how the character
will return for the upcoming Disney+ limited
series Wandavision, and while we don't know
for sure, we can hazard a pretty good guess.
It's been speculated that Wanda will use her
growing reality-warping powers to create a
nice little alternate universe, one in which
Vision is still alive and that this action
might lead to some serious trouble.
We learned from the events of Avengers: Endgame
that alternate timelines and realities are
not things which one should tamper with lightly.
If Wanda's abilities evolve to be consistent
with her powers in the comics, her meddling
might end up causing serious problems.
Those problems might require a doctor's assistance.
It's already been announced that the events
of WandaVision will tie directly into Doctor
Strange sequel, Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness.
All things considered, we appear to be looking
at one heck of a double-edged sword.
On the one hand, everyone loves Vision, and
he's coming back.
On the other, his return will almost certainly
lead to a massive threat to all of existence.
We suppose you've got to take the bad with
the good.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.